So one very popular approach would be to
combine the magnetic disks with Flash. The magnetic
disk is very cheap per gigabyte compared to
flash. We know how to build huge capacity magnetic
disks in a relatively small package, but it's
very power hungry. It spends and consumes power
even when not accessing data. And it's very
slow because it has to mechanically move things around
in order to access data. And another disadvantage of
magnetic disks is that they are sensitive to impact.
Like if they fall down and hit the ground,
while they are spinning, because their heads are then likely
to scratch the surface of the disk and permanently
damage the whole track possibly, and maybe the head
itself. Flash on the other hand, is fast, power
efficient, and has no moving parts. So if it falls
down, it might get damaged, but it's very unlikely. So the idea is to have both
of them, and use the flash effectively as a cache for the disk. That way most
of the data is on the disk, but the data we're frequently accessing is on the
flash where it's fast, it can be accessed
without moving parts, and it can be accessed
very efficiently. Now of course the disk would still
be spinning if we occasionally access it, but if
we have enough flash to access data in it
for even minutes at a time, we can actually
power down the disk and spin it down, and
only really access it once we have a flash
miss. And because both of these can keep their
data without power, if we turn off power suddenly,
the data in the flash will still survive, and
so will the data on the disk. Unlike for
example, if we use a magnetic disk with a
DRAM cache to keep the most recently accessed data.